you and Mark uh your your wonderful
husband empty nesters I can't believe it
well we're kind of empty nesters and
then my mom had heart surgery so now
we're living with my parents
and Mark's like that didn't take long
Kelly Ripa and her hubby Mark Consuelos
are no longer living the empty nester
life I will say the best part is there's
no laundry in our house there's no
dishes there's like nothing nothing
there's nothing the two have been
enjoying their new chapter after their
youngest son Joaquin went to college
last year but as Kelly tells Seth Meyers
on his late night show the kids are gone
but some new roomies have moved in her
and Mark's parents yeah the nest is full
again what happened to our Nest yeah we
love collectively all of our parents and
we it and we appreciate that they fall
apart in different stages like right
yeah so it's not like they're all with
us all at once they're a thoughtful
elderly people the couple's eldest
kiddos 25 Michael and 21 year old Lola
have been living on their own for a few
years now but it didn't make it easier
when 19 year old Joaquin left the house
people would say to us oh don't blink
because they grow up before you know it
and they'll be out of the house but we
did we blinked unfortunately and now
they are grown adults so you know I
think that's really
the worst part is that we didn't we
didn't slow down in real time to
appreciate
that aspect of them when they were small
because we were so busy protecting them
and making sure they were turning into
good people and getting things done and
getting things done is exactly what the
Consuelos kids are doing Lola's busy
studying music at NYU and just released
her first single paranoia silver lining
[Music]
and Michael he's following in Kelly and
Mark's acting footsteps starring in the
steamy new Lifetime movie Let's Get
Physical alongside Jenna Dewan Sadie and
I own the new health and fitness center
Dazzle and spin
pretty warm already and get this Kelly
and Mark are co-executive producers on
the film with Jenna so it begs the
question what's it like when Mom and Dad
suddenly become your bosses it's not
just on this my parents are my bosses in
life you know
um and yeah I mean
you know I definitely uh
there's pluses obviously I you know it's
easy some things are easier and some
things are a lot harder you know I gotta
well you always bring your A game which
is this is their you know they had a big
hand in this so I wanted to make sure I
did a really good job because they were
watching
um yeah you know so I think it it was a
good motivator it would definitely
knowing that they were involved
[Music]
thank you